>> THE BORDER SURGE FROM MEXICO
TO THE U.S. PREDICTED TO BECOME
CATASTROPHIC, 10,000 ILLEGAL
MIGRANTSES COULD ARRIVE DAILY
ONCE TITLE 42 ENDS IN EIGHT DAYS
NOW.
CALIFORNIA GOVERNOR NEWSOM
THOUGHT IT WAS GOOD TIME TO HEAD
TO THE BORDERS, VISITING A
SUPPORT CENTER, DIDN'T MEET WITH
BORDER PATROL.
>> GOT BACK FROM MEXICALI, I MET
WITH THE GOVERNOR AND
HUMANITARIAN LEADERS AND
MIGRANTS FROM HAITI, GUATEMALA
AND MEXICO WAITING FOR ASYLUM
PROCESSING.
WE ARE ON THE OTHER SIDE IN
CALEXICO TO UNDERSTAND WHAT THE
WORLD LOOKS LIKE PRE-TITLE 42
AND WHAT IT WILL LOOK LIKE
POST-TITLE 42.
>> THE SHOW IS NOT LONG ENOUGH
TO DETAIL HIS POLICY FAILURE, PR
ASPECTS, IT IS SPRAZING GIVEN
SOMEONE GROOMED HIS ENTIRE
DECADE LONG CAMPAIGN FOR
PRESIDENT FRANKLY ON HOW HE
APPEARS SOCIALLY AND IN THE PR
ARENA, WHY HAS HE GOTTEN THIS SO
WRONG?
>> Charles: IT COULD BE HE'S
ADHERING TO THIS IDEOLOGY OR
HE'S IN SO DEEP HE CAN'T TURN
BACK.
THIS IS A DIFFICULT JOURNEY FOR
WOMEN AND YOUNG GIRLS IN
PARTICULAR AND TO SORT OF SAY TO
THE WORLD, WE'RE OPEN, IF YOU
CAN GET TO THE BORDER, YOU'RE
IN, YOU ARE LURING THEM IN AND
CULPABILITY THE GOVERNMENT
SHOULD TAKE SANCTUARY CITIES AND
SOMEONE LIKE NEWSOM IS SAYING
COME ON IN.
A YOUNG LADY WHO USED TO DO MY
WIFE'S NAILS, HER DAUGHTER CAME
AND SHE WAS MISING FOR A WEEK,
HER JOURNEY WAS THREE WEEKS LONG
AND FOR ONE WEEK THEY HAD TO PAY
OFF THE COYOTES, MAFIA, THE
FAMILY GOT TOGETHER AND PUT THIS
TOGETHER.
IT IS SO DANGEROUS TO -- TALK
ABOUT HUMANITARIAN CRISIS, TO
LURE PEOPLE INTO THIS COUNTRY
LIKE THAT IS A SIN, I THINK, IT
IS NOT RIGHT.
>> Emily: HARRIS, FOR A GOVERNOR
WHO HAS DEEP-SEEDED EXPERIENCE,
HOW CAN HE NOT ACKNOWLEDGE LAW
ENFORCEMENT OR BORDER PATROL AND
THE ROLE THEY PLAY?
HE CAN ADHERE TO THAT IDEOLOGY
WHILE SAYING I SUPPORT BORDER
PATROL DOING WORK.
>> Harris: NO, HE CAN'T, THAT
WON'T HELP WITH HIS NEXT JOB, HE
WANTS TO RUN FOR PRESIDENT, HE
KEEPS TELLING US HE DOESN'T, BUT
TRAVELS ALL OVER SO HE CAN SAY
HE WENT TO THE BORDER.
I DON'T THINK IT HELPS
POLITICALLY, HE HAS A WALL IN
HIS STATE, HE'S HAVING A
DIFFERENT EXPERIENCE AND SO DOES
KAMALA HARRIS, I USED TO LIVE
THERE, I UNDERSTAND.
WE WOULD GO DOWN TO TIJUANA,
DIFFERENT SITUATION, WHERE YOU
COULD SHOP, CAN'T DO THAT NOW.
I GOT MARRIED EIGHT MILES FROM
THE BORDER AND IT IS A VERY
DIFFERENT SITUATION.
NOW WE'RE OVERRUN, THEY ARE NOT
GOING TOECK WHICH  --
CHECKPOINTS, THEY GO HERE AND
LET FENTANYL CROSS UNATTENDED,
THERE ARE AREAS POROUS AND SO
MANY OF THEM IN PLACES WHERE
BILL MELUGIN IS REPORTING IN THE
DEL RIO SECTOR.
WE HAVE DECIDED WE DON'T WANT TO
HOLD THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
ACCOUNTABLE, THEY HAD A CHA
CHANCE TO DO IT AND VOTERS MADE
THAT DECISION, AS VOTING PUBLIC,
WE HAVE TO LOOK AND WONDER, WHO
DOES THIS BENEFIT.
WE'RE IN THE SITUATION WHERE
INFLATION IS HIGH AND I TALKED
WITH STEVE FORBES LAST HOUR AND
HE SAID THIS MAKES IT WORSE,
SOMEBODY WILL HAVE TO SUPPORT
THESE PEOPLE WHO JOBS GO AWAY
AND PEOPLE FEEL PRESSURE MUCH
THE MONTHS AND MONTHS LONG OF
HIGH PRICES AND WEAKER, WEAKER,
WEAKER ECONOMY, STAGFLATION.
>> Emily: THE ONES WHO COULD
FLEE DID, THE ONES WHO DIDN'T
ARE SADDLED INCOMPETENCE OF
GOVERNOR NEWSOM ADMINISTRATION
AND GOING TO BE LEFT HOLDING
THAT DILUTED RESOURCE STRUCTURE
THAT HARRIS ARTICULATED AS THE
RUSH HOUR COMMENCES.
>> Kennedy: IS DRAINING THE
RESOURCES OF A ONCE GREAT STATE
AND COMPLAINING REPUBLICANS ARE
BOTCHING IMMIGRATION AND BRO,
THE PRESIDENT IS A DEMOCRAT,
BOTH HOUSES ARE HELD BY
DEMOCRATS, THEY EASILY COULD
HAVE TACKLED THIS ISSUE AND
COULD HAVE GIVEN IT IMMIGRATION
SOLUTIONS, THEY CHOSE NOT TO DO
THAT.
TALK ABOUT SOMEONE PASSIVE HERE
ISSUE THE VICE PRESIDENT, THE
BORDER CZARINA HAS DONE NOTHING,
NEWSOM IS TRYING TO CONTRAST
HIMSELF WITH VICE PRESIDENT
HARRIS BY SAYING I'M AT THE
BORDER IN MEXICO, IT IS
MEANINGLESS AND POLITICAL
THEATER AND TO CHARLES POINT,
THERE ARE LIVES 59 STAKE AND
LIVES BEING LOST OF THE MOST
VULNERABLE, SHAME ON ALL OF
THEM, ESPECIALLY NEWSOM.
HE DOES NOT DESERVE TO BE
PRESIDENT AND CERTAINLY NOT ON
THIS ISSUE.
>> Jackie: THAT IS RIGHT, THEY
HAVE LOST SIGHT OF THE FACT HE'S
EVER CALIFORNIA'S GOVERNOR, HE
IS ONLY GOVERNOR OF LEFT WING
TINY MINUTE PEOPLE WHO LIVE
THERE AND SUPPORT IDEOLOGY AND
POLITICAL THEATER.
>> AND PART OF TURNING BLOOIN
EYE TO WHAT IS HAPPENING, THE
ACTUAL CRISIS, CHARLES POINT OUT
OF TREKKING ACROSS THE BORDER,
THEY ARE TRYING TO IFRJ CHA
DEMOGRAPHICS IN THIS COUNTRY,
THEY WANT PEOPLE TO TURN RED
STATES PURPLER AND EVENTUALLY
BLUE AND THAT IS THE PLAN OF THE
DEMOCRATS AND WHAT HE'S PLAYING
INTO.
HARRIS, HOW MUCH THIS IS
COSTING, THE FED WILL RAISE
RATES 7.1% IS HIGH, TWO MILLION
PEOPLE WILL LOSE JOBS NEXT YEAR
AND SUPPORT CAUSES AND PEOPLE
COMING INTO THE COUNTRY.
IT IS GOING TO BE A ROUGH 2023.
>> Harris: NOBODY TURNS STATE
FROM RED TO PURPLE THE WAY GAVIN
NEWSOM DID, GO TO ARIZONA,
PEOPLE WHO FLED CALIFORNIA AND
USHG-HAULS ON THE WAY TO FLORIDA
HAVE HAD IMPACT POLITICALLY
STATES ALONG THE BORDER,
PARTICULARLY ARIZONA.
>> SHOWS IMPACT ONE GOVERNOR CAN
HAVE, I DON'T RECOGNIZE